Good afternoon. Thank you all for
coming. It is very important in the
first place that we remember why we are
here. And that doesn't just go back to
the events of the last few weeks. Let's
recall for a moment that right after
9/11, we all heard again and again and
again that all the mo Muslims in the
United States were moderate and
completely rejected and denounced and
abhored the terrorist attack that
happened on September 11th, 2001. But
what happened then? What happened after
that? What happened after that was the
beginning of a systematic campaign that
is completely inconsistent with that
claim because the claim was that
moderate Muslims
rejected 9/11 rejected terrorism. And
yet everyone who has stood up against
jihad terror, everyone who has spoken
out about this evil has been demonized
and smeared and tarred and marginalized.
And make no mistake, this is no
accident. This is two halves of the same
coin, two sides of the same coin. That
on the one hand, there was the violent
attack. But on the other hand, and we
have to recognize this, there has been a
10-year, 11-year campaign now to make
sure that everyone who is working to
resist the encroachment of the same
ideology that motivated those 9/11
attacks, everyone who is working to
raise awareness about the nature of
Islamic law and how it is in
contradiction to the freedom of speech
and to the freedom of conscience and to
the principles of the equality of rights
of all people before the law. Everyone
who has done that has been freezed,
isolated, and tred with the most serious
charges that are never substantiated
because they never can be substantiated.
And the ultimate end goal is to make
people afraid to resist. And they think
that if we speak out against jihad
terror that it's racism and bigotry.
Well, what race is jihad terror? What
race is blowing up innocent civilians in
an office building? What race is
that? How is it bigotry to fight for the
freedom of speech and equality of rights
of all
people? What we see here is a concerted
effort to disarm the American people in
the societal struggle that has followed
9/11.
What we see was manifested most vividly
in an event that happened around the
Fort Dicks aborted jihad attack. You may
not know, everybody knows about the Fort
Hood jihad attack that the Obama
administration calls workplace
violence. Very few people know that
there was a group of Muslims a couple of
years before that who were planning to
go into Fort Dicks and to murder as many
American soldiers as they could before
they were themselves killed. Fort Dick.
Now look, how did the Fort Dick Six get
caught? I'll tell you. They got caught
because they liked to watch gory jihad
videos. They liked to watch Daniel Pearl
being beheaded and other videos of that
kind. And they had them all on VHS
tapes. So they took them to a video
store and said, "Can you put this on DVD
for
us?" It's true story. And so this kid in
the video store is working and he's
seeing these horrible images and he
stops and he goes to his manager. And
you know what he said to the manager?
Now this kid is a hero, don't get me
wrong, because he did stop. He did go to
the police, but before he went to the
police, he said to his manager, "I've
seen these horrible things on these
videos and I think these guys are up to
no good. Should I call the police or
would that be racist?
True story. It's ridiculous. It's
absurd. And it's what's happening in
American life every day
now that people who stand up against
what happened on 9/11 and all the other
attempts to advance the same
ideology, they get the same kind of
treatment. So that the ultimate end goal
is that people are too intimidated and
too frightened because nobody wants to
be called a racist. Nobody wants to be
called a bigot. And it can destroy your
professional career. It can destroy your
personal life. And that's why they do
it. And so what we come to today is a
tremendous abuse of power and the public
trust. Hhabib Ahmed is on the Nassau
County Human Rights Commission. And in
his capacity on the Nassau County Human
Rights Commission, he attempted to do
this same thing to Pamela Geller so that
decent people would be afraid and
ashamed to stand with her and to host
her. And this is not the only time this
has happened. This has happened many
times. As a matter of fact, anytime any
of us who are in this field and fighting
against this are invited to speak in a
public venue, the same campaign happens.
They do it to me. They did it to Noni
Darwish. They do it to
everyone. Hhabib Ahmed took it one step
further because Hhabib Ahmed used his
capacity on the Nassau County Human
Rights Commission to drum up support for
his smear campaign.
And ultimately he was able to get the
ball rolling on a campaign of defamation
and lies and smears that did end up
getting Pamela Geller canled from the
Great Neck Synagogue. Now we all know
there were great and courageous people
who stepped up who were at Habad this
morning and who hosted her there. You're
here and that was a great victory.
But it was one victory in a larger
struggle. And the larger struggle is
that we must not allow not only this
abuse of the public trust and his public
office by Habib Ahmed, but we must stand
up every time they do this and say, "No,
truth is not bigotry. Truth is not
hatred. And defending freedom of speech
and equality of rights for all people is
not bigotry or racism. And we are not
going to stand for it. We are not going
to stand for this towering of good
people, heroic people who are fighting
to preserve our rights and to defend our
freedoms. Because if we do not
stand, and I know I'm preaching to the
choir because you're all out here, and I
thank you that you're here, and I thank
God that you're here. But at the same
time, we have to remember it's not just
today, and it's not just this incident,
and it's not just Habib Ahmed. They do
this every time. They will keep doing
this every time. And we have to be with
them every step of the way and expose
who they are and expose their own ties
to the Muslim Brotherhood and to other
Islamic supremacist
groups and to show these people are not
neutral civil rights organizations. The
Council on American Islamic Relations,
these people are
Hamas and they are enemies of American
freedoms and we are going to defend
American freedoms. We are going to
pledge like the fi signers of the
Declaration of Independence our lives,
our fortunes, and our sacred honor to
the defense of freedom. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.